le gouvernement du canada a annoncé pour
plus de 250 milliards de dollars de
soutien aux canadiens d'où viennent donc
ces milliards et qui va payer surtout
avec nous ce soir l'économiste françois
delorme bonsoir françois de l'homme
bonsoir je rentre comment le soutien
public du gouvernement fédéral qui très
important jusqu'à maintenant va modifier
l'état des finances publiques à moyen
terme les temps des finances publiques
va changer énormément le gouvernement
fédéral ne prévoyait pas on avait un
ratio de déficit par rapport aux pertes
aux deux points 4 % qu'est ce qui était
prévu en 2024 25
maintenant il n'y avait pas de dedans on
envisager pas de retour à l'équilibré
budgétaire du moins officiellement dans
les documents budgétaires avec
l'intervention publique qui était
annoncé jusqu'à hier on peut s'attendre
à ce que le déficit augmente en
proportion du pib autour de 10%
et ça c'est sans compter les choses qui
ne sont pas réglés encore 2010 morneau
vous disiez en entrevue qu'il était prêt
à aider encore et que tous les canadiens
seraient aurez droit à une assistance
mais ça touche aussi à des industries
clés
on parle maintenant d'un sauvetage ou
d'une aide financière avec le transport
aérien dirigé aussi dans l'industrie du
tourisme
on vous dresse son pays ou si
l'industrie du pétrole en alberta et ça
ça ferait monter le ratio là si on
annonçait sa avec les schistes qui
circulent en ce moment autour de 15 % du
pib
donc c'est sûr que d'après mes calculs
on reviendrait pas à l' équilibre
budgétaire
dans le cas de ce qui était annoncé
jusqu'à hier à vingt six ans et si on
bouffait de prêter assistance aux trois
industries auxquels j'ai parlé ça
prendrait encore une dizaine d'années
avant d'envisager un retour avec les
budgétaire selon mes calculs gros
déficit et grosses dates supplémentaires
qui va payer pour ça après françois
delorme qui va payer pour ça on sait pas
qui veut payer pour ça mais l'idée c'est
que ça il va falloir que ça se paye un
moment donné et est ce que ça va être
les contribuables qui vont payer pour ça
est ce qu il peut avoir c'est ce qu'ils
ont peut pas
l'essai on peut pas rester à des niveaux
aussi important et il va voir un retour
frères la consolidation budgétaire
alors est-ce que ça va être les revenus
des ménages qui vont être taxés est-ce
que ça va être les entreprises où est ce
qu'on va revenir gerald c'est ce qui
m'inquiète un peu a dit des périodes de
consolidation budgétaire comme on a un
ancien ministre du québec qui qui aimait
qualifié ce genre d'exercice la dot
rappelé à de l'austérité mais c'est sûr
que où les taxes ou les dépenses vont
devoir être cuit pour retourner sur le
chemin de l'équilibré budgétaire à ses
attaques
donc est ce que les ménages les mieux
nantis pour être appelés à payer plus
d'impôts éventuellement ah ben on
pourrait toujours faire payer les plus
riches encore aujourd'hui le taux
marginal d'impôt pour les gens qui
gagnent au dessus de deux cent quatorze
mille dollars au québec le taux combiné
ses 53 points 3 % alors il n'y a pas de
raisons pour lesquelles on pourrait nous
on pourrait ne pas augmenter seront
pourrait le faire mais c'est certain que
comme d'habitude que ce soit au niveau
des entreprises où que ce soit au niveau
des particuliers
il ya toujours des considérations de
compétitivité fiscale avec les les
juridictions qui qui qui sont adjacentes
au québec alors théoriquement il ya rien
qui empêche de faire payer les hauts
revenus mais il ya d'autres
considérations qui joue avant de faire
avec la force de l'intervention des
gouvernements des banques centrales est
ce qu'on est en train d'assister à une
forme de socialisation de l'économie
avec avec la présence de l'état des
gouvernements beaucoup plus important
dans l'activité économique mais c'est
certain que c'est un certain changement
d'intervention d'habitude les économies
sont plutôt d'accord au tous mais en
général les économistes sont d'accord
avec des interventions temporaire le ce
qu'on voit c'est quelque chose qu'on ne
jamais vu à 20 à ce niveau là et ce
qu'ils on voit que au fédéral vous
l'avez dit on à en annoncer des mesures
autour de 200 milliards la banque du
canada
injecte des liquidités importantes pour
garder les taux d'emprunt faible est ce
qu'on voit au canada on le voit partout
au royaume uni aux états unis et dans la
plupart du g20 alors ce mouvement le
nous amène à une présence beaucoup plus
importante de l'état dans l'économie et
la part des dépenses de programme par
exemple l'intervention du fédéral et
autour de 15% du pib mais l'année
prochaine ou dans deux ans on pourrait
voir sa montée à 25 ou 30 pour ça et
c'est d'habitude la façon dont on mesure
le degré d'intervention publique dans
une économie par un état alors dans les
pays du g7 on voit exactement la même
chose et on arrive à des niveaux
historiques de 40% des dépenses de
programmes en portant sion de la taille
de l'économie donc on voit que c'est
extrêmement important et un mouvement
vert plus d'interventions et ça va
devenir une nouvelle normalité vous
pensez mais je sais pas mais j'ai
l'impression qu'on se dirige vers
quelque chose qu'on a pas vu à 20 et moi
je dis toujours que ce qui est notable
ou ce qui est dangereux en guinée ce
sont les précédents et une une
intervention de cette nature et de cette
importance le pourrai sculpter les
attentes dans le sens où maintenant si
on assistait à une nouvelle crise par
exemple l'année prochaine ou dans deux
ans ou une récession profonde
on pourrait s'attendre à ce que nous on
pourrait envisager que les contribuables
ou les entreprises vont s'attendre à des
sauvetages maintenant alors la
perception par rapport aux risques ou
par rapport à la façon dont l'économie
de marché fonctionne bien c'est sûr que
ça change un peu la donne
à ce niveau-là d'économie sa calculé que
dans une cinquantaine de pays
les dépenses publiques en proportion du
pib avait augmenté dans les 30 dernières
années donc on voit qu'il ya une
certaine forme de deux interventions
publiques qui s'enracine dans les
économies occidentales
françois delorme merci pour cette
analyse ce soir je vous en prie ça me
plaisait